I love pie like a cow plant pound pound
bank downtown
I'm fine capital GZ table aduba top oh
but the hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I'm back on I'm happy
oh boy oh ok so we're back here with
unfair Mario we've only got three levels
to go I'm gonna beat it alright and hard
mode engage right now I'm gonna try to
get through this without saying a single
curse word let's see how long I last
with that okay anyway so here we go ha
oh yeah I forgot ah ha wait wait a
minute wait a minute hang on I wasn't
ready hooray
hang on I need to go under that one then
over and under but can't go under need
to go over it ok under over way over
under Oh piss no hang on I got this over
oh whoa ah screw you
ok piss is not curse word I can say piss
is so much as I want
oh ok so huh
okay alright I know I didn't want to do
that thank you
ok got it up here here oh there through
up Sarge
ok I gotta I'm trying to remember
exactly where ha ha yes and then ah pass
hmm ok up over under Oh
I jumped I jumped I had to jump on it
didn't go after some ah son of a monkey
I had to jump
I had to John I hit I hit I hit that
jump I hit it I had the jump button the
John button was struck it depressed some
wrong with I keep [ __ ]
No
all right I guess it was that wasn't
gonna last very long anyway so far I
mean fudge ha ha ha ha ha ha last you
have your Eiffel Towers stuck in my
toaster ah okay ah
jump I got jump like hang on I haven't
quite figured it out already I yeah I'm
about to approach the big 200 Ok Go here
that I jump just here and then I jump
over that fudge Farquaad okay jump to
here fern Anna yeah
ha ha Java oh did you call me fer mamas
survivor sama my boosah ah Oh chucka
buffer whoa come on come on
ah I had that I had it Jerry Maguire urn
huh runner haba haba ocean or me well
former that's a trap I trap what am i
well what am I supposed to do there how
about you go screw yourself
ok man this is like this was hard
ah Bob Saget
ah Ramona I have an aneurysm in this
game ah Martha Stewart Jesus balls okay
uh duppa Haydar Pattabhi horn ah I knew
that was gonna happen I knew it was
gonna happen yet I did nothing to
prevent it
that's my bouche wha bass get off uh
yeah uh oh oh man there's got to be by
far the most difficult one that I've
come across
okay so what am I supposed to do here
hey brah
ah ha ah no no kill me don't kill me bro
don't do it bro now what am I about to
do here ah balls to you finally Megan's
of progress and oops nope can't do that
gosh cut you off at the pass halt halt
with your to wisdom tooth tail Hodge oh
I was so close I almost made that but
close doesn't matter not in this game oh
I had the jump you could hear Mikey
clack you can hear it clack why don't
you do that why I know that the giant
flashing run sign doesn't help me much
either
ah uh uh oh yeah ah ah I'm just gonna
jump for it well that was wrong
what am I gonna do they're not much of
an explanation going on there oh man ah
- I am
faboo boy I'm odd the blue ah I music
end annoying
I'm I turn it off Jesus
ah pop at the button I push it the
button and you don't work
uh-uh
yes master
ha ha ah firms in my room
ah ha pepper this is not going very well
I'm just I even if I get past to where I
want to go it's just like whoa hey now
come up
ah man like I don't know how I'm gonna
get past this level but what I do I
don't even think I'm gonna be happy
about it like uh uh I haven't been happy
in years
oh you son of a monkey your beat is this
Noblin Beatles's ah no ah man you stupid
clouds I see you're back there mocking
me with your smiles judging me I see you
are dirty too judging me I'd like to see
you do any better but not God [ __ ] ice
land right on top of him ah I'm a mommy
hello I'm a mama oh my mommy oh mama
mama mama mama I hate my life why did I
choose to come back I could have left
gracefully ha ha ha I can't even get
past this one level well Lord ghosting
dushman gurbin Oh No ah kana let's just
get past this we haven't been able to do
that in a long time ok there we go
now get Oh what where what why ah ok
perfection ma thy name is what the [ __ ]
Mario seriously you're gonna slide off
of that you know that's gonna kill you
and you just chose to slide off anyway
you didn't want to you didn't even care
you're just like ah my life is filled
with such pain ah I wasn't even near him
huh okay okay all right I'm tired of
being aggravated let's just engage Pro
Mode and decide that suddenly we're
gonna be awesome
okay okay now I need to know what the
hell I'm supposed to do here what am I
supposed to do
ah ah there there it is okay at least I
know where it is
you son of a mother aah Oh what I I
jumped
I'm holding down the hot button when I
move for a [ __ ] it did that on purpose
just to screw with me
I would laugh now and be surprised too
somehow somehow every time someone logs
into this game the game makers are like
oh so stupid idiot it's decided to play
our game again ha ha ha
and they're just like ah ha you just
find new ways they're French too I bet
I just bet they're friends I can't even
get past these parts I've been doing for
10 kajillion hours we're wrong with me
Jesus balls j-just get past apart you've
been stupid Mario this isn't even my
fault anymore it's all Mario such an
[ __ ] to look at him there else cocky
gets probably its pain for every time he
dies what a weirdo ok so it's right
where is it right there ok is that gonna
be enough
I don't care here we go oh my god oh
yeah thereby oh ha ha ha ha [ __ ] hell
what the hell did I do wrong did I just
not go quick enough is that really that
really I just got to go quick you're
kidding me you can't off [ __ ] you and
your stupid patrolling ways
I just gotta get out of there like fast
that's all like oh you son of a [ __ ] I
wanna die
not again in here I want it like real
life dead all sorts of like mangled
corpse and all that jazz all the good
stuff oh man I swear I'm gonna I'm gonna
stab someone enough fish ah gimme
just give me there come on we gotta go
come on Mario do it no I don't get it
got it you stupid [ __ ] now go now
okay huh huh the [ __ ] no no uh-uh oh
that's a much better way to go ah make
it you dick come on off oh jeez oh good
come on come on I didn't even know I
could do that find a [ __ ] hell if I
get the right spot god damn it I'm so
pissed get get up there and go and go
for it and nail it in the wall yeah this
is much more efficient Oh get in there
yeah I had the gap yes oh my god Brody's
little 99,000 Oh Oh get to [ __ ] you
Mario come on move you dick get it get
it touch it touch it go go go
Doodlebug come on
fresh Oh oh man ha ha ha Jesus holy crap
I made it I can't believe I made it I
made it guys I made it
there's secret block up here I'm man who
can't believe I made it
hi McAra what happens I'm just gonna I
don't even care what happens now
hey what's over here hey there's
something over here hey oops Todd didn't
make that one hey I guess Oh [ __ ] be
a [ __ ] go come on Oh Oh what I can make
it before but I can't make it now
ah man Robert oh ha ha ha I saw that
can't hide from me
gonna get it it to win it
ah ah fetch ruff
well that was dumb nah ah so close and
yet so far got balls - balls balls aroni
come on draw just yeah
yeah ba-ba-ba-ba-bom well alright then
ah ba ba bum ah what hey on this there's
a message over there I got to read it
ha [ __ ] I got it how do I get the fudge
over there come on dammit what done so
like nothing all screw you buddy
well I wasn't even all right whatever
there's a message over there I want to
read it I am
I learn ah you won't finish the level
this way all right whatever okay so I
shut up you okay I'm only one away from
the and ah oh man I'm doing good I'm
doing good I'm doing good man that took
a long time jeez I can't believe it I
must have the will and strength of a
thousand gods
I am so amazing in all that Jess okay so
I'll finish this last episode in an epic
hour-long finale however long last up
closes get levels gonna take me I don't
even know this sucks
yes sucks but hopefully you guys are
enjoying it some thank you all so much
for watching click the annotation for
more video since I've done and as always
I will see you in the next video
Oh
bud